My name is Max Tarmossin,
and I'm the owner and
operator of ColorGlo GTA.
Our main job is to refresh and restore
interior components of vehicles.
Today, I'll be walking you through
how I'm restoring the driver's seat
on the 2006 Ferrari 360 Spider.
The problem with the driver's seat
is that over the years of use,
there's obvious signs of wear and tear.
The original dye has
faded, it started cracking.
The leather has started
to wrinkle and fold up
and deform itself.
The first thing that I do with this car
is I start by removing the
seat from the vehicle itself.
That makes it much easier to work on,
and when I end up spraying the dye,
I don't have to mask
off the entire interior.
Once the seat is out of the car,
I put it on my worktable
and I start by dismantling
the seat itself.
I'm removing the main bottom
cushion and the top cushion
to expose the bolsters of the seat.
This makes my life a lot easier,
because I gain access to
all the little crevices
that are found in the seat.
I start by fully cleaning the seat.
I have my own cleaning mixture.
I spray the seat down, and
I start off with a brush,
and I start agitating the seat
to lift the dirt up from the leather
that's been in there for years.
This is a very crucial step,
because I want a clean working slate.
The reason for that is
when I'll be applying
the fillers and the dyes,
it has something to stick on
and there's no grease or oils
that could alter or affect my products.
I use a soft horsehair brush
to get into all the little crevices
and to clean up the threads,
and then I follow up by
drying it with a hair dryer.
I could leave it to dry by itself,
but I find that it's much quicker
and I can see any parts that I missed
because they still remain
shiny and not matte.
Once the cleaning has been fully done,
then I start by sanding the leather down.
It creates trenches in the leather
that enables my product
to bond with the leather
to have proper adhesion.
I'm removing the old dye
that's all cracked up,
and I'm exposing the natural
hide on the seat itself.
I usually start with 120 grit,
and I work my way up to 400 grit.
The smooth finish is needed
because once I start applying the dye,
you don't want the leather to be
still uneven when the dye lays on it,
and looks natural, clean, and uniform.
Then I start filling in any imperfections,
scratches with our crack filler.
Our fillers are flexible
because leather is flexible
and we can't be using a stiff filler.
I use an artist's spatula.
It allows me to fill the cracks
but also remove the excess
filler from the top surface.
I carefully go around the entire seat.
I let that sit to dry for a bit,
and, once again, I go back to sanding.
It creates a smooth, uniform finish.
I start by mixing the color.
In this case, the color is black,
so it's fairly simple.
I'm pouring my base into the green cup.
Then I pour the black pigment.
Once I've established the ratio
for how consistent I need the dye to be,
I move on to the next step,
and that is starting to hand-rub
the dye into the leather.
It allows the dye to be sucked
into those trenches and valleys,
and it allows the leather
to really absorb our dye
and to hang onto it.
I go over the entire seat.
Once I've done that, I pour
the dye into my spray gun
and I add additives to my dye.
So, in this case, the
additives that I've added
was a no-gloss additive.
Usually a full seat receives
about three to four coats of dye.
Once I've been spraying,
the white crack filler
is no longer visible,
and that's what I'm aiming at.
I take out my second gun,
and now into that gun I mix in
the same leather base that I started with,
but without any black pigment,
and this serves as a
clear coat for the seat,
which separates the
black dye from the user.
Curing takes about a day,
then I go ahead and reinstall the seat.